foreign
let's go to Margaret in Arlington what's
up Margaret
Hi how are you I'm sorry to hear about
James I know what a quitter right but
it's okay that's okay we're doing good
without him we've got a great game
that's right we got yes we got two
brilliant women running the show now so
that's awesome
what's up
um yeah so I will first thank you for
taking my call
um I was hoping
um that you could give me some advice on
how to
um basically let go of the anger and
resentment that I feel towards my sister
so that I can better help her and
support her through her eating disorder
and Recovery oh man that's tough how old
is she how old are y'all
well we're we're Twins and we're 33. I'm
so beautiful
lead with that Margaret lead with that
all right so 33 twins is extra personal
uh yeah so we're pretty close tell me
about your sister
um well it's over 33 we she was first
diagnosed with anorexia when we were 14.
have you ever have you ever wrestled
with distorted eating
no no not me personally have you ever
wrestled with any sort of anxiety
yeah
um
yeah I had some bad like postpartum
anxiety and depression a couple years
ago when I had my daughter okay what
about when you were young
I'm sorry what about when you were young
when I was young no no
there's depression in my family and my
dad is bipolar okay
um so there is some family history with
mental illness there but 14 15 16 like
your childhood
um your teenage years you walked
alongside your sister while she was
really struggling but you didn't have
similar struggles just somewhere else
it cracked okay wow okay all right let's
go ahead so okay so she
um she's 14. we were 14 when she was
first diagnosed it was very severe
um for several years she was in and out
of hospitals and treatment centers
um and then I would say in our 20s
um she she got to a good place where she
was coping with it and managing it
um living a full productive life we were
all kind of like reads easy for a while
um and then
a couple years ago right around the time
that covet hit she quit her job to stay
at home with her daughters to be a
stay-at-home mom
um and then
she started gobbling again in like diets
and workout programs and at first it was
just oh I want to lose the baby weight
but it was only a couple like a matter
of a couple of months maybe before she
was falling spiraling again yeah
um and she's back now basically where we
were when uh where she was when we were
14 and
extremely severe
case she's been in two treatment
programs in the last two years
um like inpatient treatment programs the
first one she checked herself out early
AMA because she just didn't want to be
there anymore right and then the second
time she was actually kicked out early
because she wasn't following the roles
of the program
and I guess
you know on top of the stress and the
worry and the concern that I have for
her
um
I just struggle a lot with anger towards
these choices that she's making and
um and I feel like
this time is different
um I like I know that she can get better
and move on
um because I've seen her do it before
but this time feels different it feels
like she's giving up and she's told me
that when she feels like her family is
upset with her or angry with her
um that she just
um shuts down and doesn't want to fight
it anymore so but the reality is is I am
angry
and I'm it's hard not to watch her
um you know I hear you say a lot that
behavior is a language or like yeah
behavior is a language and her behavior
says that she just doesn't want to be
here anymore that she doesn't want to
live and that she is slowly killing
herself and making us all watch it and
it's maddening yeah yeah uh
your anger is is Justified it's okay
um don't beat yourself up and feel
guilty about it yeah don't don't feel
horrible for being mad because I know
it's like I get it it's a serious mental
illness and
it's not like she can just stop right
um change yeah and normally you've heard
me say I'm I'm much more context
specific when it comes to like my ADHD
won't let me like nope you got that's no
excuse you got to figure it out right
um but when it comes to this you know
this but I I hear Mo generally that it's
the most or if the top one or two
um most lethal mental health
issues in the world and most people
don't know that anorexia kills more
people than depression right
um it's a scary thing and it's
especially scary watching somebody you
love who also is the mother of your
niece or does she have one kid two kids
Jesus
um slowly suffocate themselves
I'm so sorry so don't feel guilty about
being upset that's okay that's you'd be
a weirdo if you weren't mad okay
um there's a difference between anger
and rage right
and there's a look here's the way I
would explain it if my son I may have
explained this on the show before my if
my son gets up in the middle of the
night
and he's
um sick
and he comes into my room and says Daddy
I don't feel good and I'm like well like
what do you mean how can I help and then
he barfs all over my bed
I can be mad that I have I'm covered in
barf
I can't be mad at my little boy for
coming to the one place he knows he
feels safe when he doesn't feel good
right I can be frustrated I could tell
him don't ever barf on my bed again dude
do that somewhere else but yeah um so
you're like being mad at this situation
that the your sister who let's be honest
are y'all are y'all identical twins
no we're not identical okay fraternal
twins then yeah yeah okay you're
watching a part of yourself out there
walking around right yeah that's gotta
be tough
make peace with the tough okay
um
here's the back end like what do you do
now what do you want to do now what is
your family talking about doing what are
y'all thinking about doing
well we don't really know she um
she is resisting going back into an
inpatient program she doesn't want to do
it again
um so she's kind of fighting that
um but everybody her entire team or
doctors or therapists everyone is
telling her if you don't
get this help if you don't change these
behaviors you
will die right and
um she has she ever been involuntarily
committed
no
no
um not yet anyway okay but we're looking
at that possibility okay that's a huge
deal so people listening like why can't
you just make her go it's a huge deal to
take away somebody's civil rights that
somebody else comes in and says you're
crazy that's been abused throughout
history and so
um that's a usually a last Last Resort
when somebody's barely hanging on
another option is somebody's got to step
in and keep those kids safe
um how are those kids
I
I don't know I mean it's my biggest
concern I I think I mean they're doing
well they have a great I mean her dad
their dad is amazing um and he's doing
everything he can Okay
um you know the the thing that makes it
also difficult is they live on the other
side of the country for me so it's not
like I can just pop over yeah check in
on them or take them or whatever my
um you know my parents have gone out
there and helped out and taken them at
certain times just to help and we do
what we can but I also am extremely
worried about how this is going to
affect them
it'll affect them profoundly one yeah
yeah yeah no it'll be a huge deal
um and yeah that's going to be a
long-term Ripple through through the
family yeah
um
I can't I can think of few harder
situations than what you're in right now
and I wish I could tell you here just do
these three things and I can't
um you've got somebody that you love and
you care about and it's very close
closer to you than than probably your
husband probably her husband it's closer
like y'all are right you'll share the
womb dude you're right y'all are in it
um
watching her be so sick
that she is she's tired and she's slowly
checking out
yeah and it's I can think a few things
harder than that what I would tell you
is
in addition to the anorexia my guess is
you've reached your limit on the lying
and the secrets and just talking to you
like you're stupid you know what I mean
if you if you spent time on people at
the store to eating
they tell you things that are so
blatantly not true that it feels like
they're insulting you that you're stupid
right and it just gets exhausting to be
around like no no yesterday I'm not I
had like a five piece of pizza
a hundred percent you didn't right and
they're and just the stories get more
outlandish and sometimes it's less
watching the person be sick and it's
more just quit lying or weird Secrets or
making right just all of it turns into
this it's hard to be around yeah so
know this
she can be very very sick and
still make moves I hate to call it
manipulation because I know it's a part
of it's a function of the illness
but the lobbying grenades like when
you're mad at me it makes me just want
to die that's not fair don't own that
okay that's nonsense
um that's just that's just that's
manipulative and it's not I wouldn't
play that game the moment you say cool
I'm all in you look things are great I'm
just that's you being disingenuous right
that's not that's not cool
um I would be open and honest about how
you feel
and don't let her perfectionism and
blame and shame be cast on you and at
the same time this is going to be
probably the hardest thing you ever have
to do I would reach out to her and if
you can visit in person mm-hmm
and let her know I'm not going to try to
fix you
I can't sit here and watch you die
but I love you
I actually do have a trip planned out to
go see her okay
um and so that's also probably why I was
calling because I don't know what to say
when I do see her
I know my family wants me to I guess
kind of convince her to go back into
it yeah
um
should I know if I could if I do that or
try I know she's just gonna shut down
absolutely and and I've I've got people
close to me that have struggled with
disorder eating and you're exactly right
most people I I'm very direct with
people I love who are hurting I'm
directing everybody who's hurting and
about what they need to be to do to get
on the path of healing and this one is
hard because the moment you launch into
it they shut down they shut off right
and that's what I would tell you
sitting down with her she doesn't need
to know that she's sick she knows
what she really needs is you to hold her
hand and say I love you it's really hard
for me to watch you die
but I love you and I'll do what I can to
take care of your kids
um but I love you
and that's the only way I've found
personally I don't have any literature
on this this is just me sitting with
people the only way to get a crack in
the door to get some light in there
is that person's not trying to fix me
they're not trying to broke because I've
gotta because people with disorder even
have a game plan for that they don't
have a game plan for unconditional love
and skin to skin contact
right and you have to make space
um an analogy just came to my head and
what I'm going to tell you is going to
be very hard to hear is that okay
yeah sure okay
yeah what I'm going to tell you is real
hard to hear okay
my dad
um it was a hostage negotiator for the
SWAT team in Houston and what that meant
was when somebody was going to jump off
of a building and they would they had
gone out on the ledge and they were
hanging on barely they would call my dad
they called the team in but my dad would
be one of the guys that would go up and
sit with that person and talk to him
until they came down all right and he
told me that
he would often go up there and within
just a minute or two he knew if that
person was going to jump or not
and almost always they didn't want to
jump but he said his concern would
almost invariably move towards he
thought they were going to fall
they're going to get tired and slip
they're going to get exhausted and relax
their grip a little bit and they're
going to fall off right yeah and he said
whenever you walk into those situations
when people are at this stage of of
illness at this stage of hurt of this
stage of pain
he said you had to make sure you had
already asked yourself
am I going to watch when they jump
or am I going to listen when they hit
or am I going to cover my ears and duck
down
and here's what I'm telling you that
that lesson has been very important for
me throughout my life working with in
these moments because
you have to come up with your line
right
um am I going to watch this thing happen
in a slow motion train wreck or am I
going to call every psychiatric facility
and try to do an inval call the police
I'm gonna try to involunteer I'm going
to burn every bridge I have to keep my
sister alive
and also
I'm not going to or am I going to draw a
boundary and say
I'll call you every day I'll write you
every day but I cannot watch the end of
this thing happen like that that's a
boundary you have to draw for yourself
okay I'm somebody who will exhaust the
go to the ends of the Earth but I'm also
a realist too
and that's a hard moment for you but I
want you and the people in your
community to be prepared for if she does
take her life if she does choose I am
not getting help that hey you can sleep
knowing I did what was right for us and
B
that's not your fault
and having some space there before you
enter into these conversations is really
important
and it sounds this is a call that I
don't normally have right it sounds like
I'm kind of a defeatist
um I just have been with too many people
in your sister's situation and it's it
can be very bleak
it can be very Bleak I can also say this
never lost one not that I've never had
somebody pass away I've had people turn
the corner but only through relationship
and treatment intense treatment
um have you told her you told like I
don't want you to die have you said
those words
how did she hear that
um she just gets really quiet and she'll
say I don't want to die either or at
least that's what she used to say
um
and
you know she says she said in the past I
want to be here for my kids I don't want
to leave them
um
but like I said I I just it's different
now she's definitely it definitely feels
like she's given up and she's saying
things like well my eating disorder just
wants me dead so
I feel like that's what's gonna happen
so I think that she says that that's
fair yeah I think you're right I think
it does want you dead
she needs to want to be alive
and you've heard the old story about
sobriety like you can't get clean for
your kids you can't get clean for your
spouse you gotta get clean for you you
have to decide I want I want to I want a
different life
and most people decide they want a
different life they get to a place where
they can they don't want to hurt anymore
or they get to a place where
somebody's holding their hand and they
realize they're not alone
and use It's a combination of the two
but I think sitting if if she's if she's
if I'm in your situation I would sit
down and say I'm not here to fix you I'm
here to tell you I love you
okay you're smart you know all the
treatment plans you know all the stuff I
love you
I cannot sit here and just watch you die
and um you can let her know I'm going to
call everybody I know
I'm gonna do everything I can legally
and otherwise to force you into
treatment because I don't want to watch
you die
but I also want you to know I'm not
going to try to fix you I can't do that
right so it's a both hand
um and have that hard conversation with
yourself with your family with her
husband whoever you need to have it and
create some go all in and have some
space right
uh maybe the better way to say it is uh
run into the building that's on fire but
be connected to the oxygen hose outside
right
and that means you got to keep yourself
well during this whole thing right you
got to make sure you've got someone
you're talking to or a couple of people
you're talking to that you're eating
that you're exercising you're walking
around that you're sleeping when you can
that you're taking care of yourself so
that you can repel into this Mass
um
for those of you watching this
um
I as much as anybody
I'm all about discipline I'm all about
just do it I don't care what you feel
just go go I don't feel like working out
work out anyway that's me that's who I
am
sort of eating is something else it's a
nightmare and
um there's some compelling evidence out
there that it's it's one of the few that
is truly genetic right and it's got a
history throughout time it's not just
because social media is it that
exacerbates it but
it's been with us for a long time it is
and it is a nightmare and so just saying
you just gotta it doesn't work with
anorexia
um relationship and true desire to
change
true Relentless desire to be alive and
to be whole that's what helps people in
those moments and that can only happen
with a team of professionals
so if you are struggling with anorexia
your your worth a better life
you're worth a better life
you're worth laughing and you're worth
peace and if you love somebody who's
struggling with anorexia call everybody
call everybody get the resources you
need and when you call everybody
also let that person know I can't fix
you only you can but I love you and I'll
be here with you
I'll be here with you